Hello and welcome to the newest episode
of the Brussels Signal podcast. It is
with great pleasure that I can introduce
you today to Raymond Ibrahim. Raymond,
uh, would you do me a favor and
introduce yourself a little bit to our
guest because you are a man who is all
over the place and particularly I think
they will be curious to hear that you
have also been a librarian for quite a
while. Yes. Uh, hi Ralph, good to be
with you. A quick recap of my um,
background. um Egyptian parents born and
raised in the United States. Um
bilingual English, Arabic, some other
languages. Studied uh Islamic history
and doctrine in college. Um also did
graduate work um Georgetown University,
Catholic University when I was in
Washington DC. Worked at the Library of
Congress as a librarian. Um focused on
uh Middle Eastern languages, Arabic and
Persian, Turkish etc. And it was there
that I actually discovered the writings
of al-Qaeda back in about over 20 years
ago. And um I translated them. They were
my first book. The al-Qaeda reader came
out in 2007. And um since then I've uh
essentially been a fellow at various
think tanks just publishing and writing
articles and other books. Um and um
mostly gravitating towards my historical
focus which I had in you know
academically. Um, so my my probably my
two most famous books are my two last
ones, Sword and Scimitar, 14 centuries
of war between Islam and the West, which
chronicles all the decisive battles and
the overall context between the West and
Islam. And I'm, you know, as people will
tell you, it's very shocking. They
always say their response to that book
is, why didn't I learn any of this in
school? And well, there's a reason. And
the other book is Defenders of the West,
the Christian heroes who stood against
Islam, which is the same theme, but it's
more of a biography focused book on
various different characters, eight
eight heroes essentially. Um, and just
writing other themes that I follow are
the Muslim persecution of Christians,
which is a um, and I have a book about
that as well. Crucified again came out
2013 and that's I still follow and write
reports every month for the Gates
Institute. And it's a growing pandemic
that again it's one of those things that
few people know about or talk about. Um
and yeah that's that basically what I've
been up to. I mean you have really
emerged as one of the preeminent
thinkers on the relationship between
Islam and the west and this has been a
topic that has dominating the headlines
at least since September 11 2001. Now if
I would ask you what are some of the
perceptions that most people get wrong
when they when they think you know the
everyday person when they think about
relationship of Islam in the west or the
average journalist and what we read in
the Wall Street Journal or the New York
Times about the relationship what are
some what are some of the things that
trigger you if you excuse that
expression when you read about the
relationship between the West and Islam?
Yeah, good question. Um there there's
many things that trigger me if you want
to use that expression but um actually
they don't anymore. I'm rather jaded
about the whole thing because it's been
going on for over two decades and it
gets worse. Um but basically it's this
you know idea that you know people like
George Bush um you know proclaimed which
is Islam means peace and that anytime a
Muslim engages in any act of radicalism
or terrorism etc. we have to always come
up with an excuse to justify it. You
know it's never because the religion is
like that. it's because he has a
grievance or because you know you'd be
surprised at how many times I've come
across and I've written about this um a
Muslim who engages in typical Islamic
behavior which is to say vile and
violent against non-Muslims and whatever
the case may be and almost always and
this is especially in Europe the report
concludes that he is mentally sick
that's why he acted that way or that's
why she acted that way okay um so it's
it's this you know it's this constant
insistence that you know Islam is peace
and when Muslims act in accordance with
what I know is Islamic teaching radical
intolerant violent then they come up
with any and every excuse you can
imagine to justify it including outright
suppression so when I write it for
example I was telling you about the um
persecution of Christians that's a
serious topic and it's completely
ignored it's just suppressed because
there is no way to get around it what
Muslims have grievances that a small
minority of Christians want to pray and
so they destroy their churches So
usually what happens it's ignored and we
saw an example of this you know I think
a month ago somewhere in the Congo they
found in a church 70 Christians
decapitated by Muslims and that got a
little you know media play but that's
just the tip of the iceberg that's this
sort of thing and this and the carnage
of Christians especially in subsaharan
Africa and Nigeria as well and other
countries is is a constant and the long
and short of it is this if um if if what
Muslims do to others to non-Muslims was
the opposite. If let's say Christians
were doing this to Muslims, it would be
all over the news and you would hear
about it 24/7. The monthly report I told
you I write about Muslim persecution of
Christians. Um it's all for it's all
anecdotes that I find from various
websites and they're all small human
rights organizations etc. And none of
them generally make it to the mainstream
media. But if it was the opposite, if it
was a Christian doing whatever I'm
reporting Muslims are doing to
Christians, it wouldn't make it all over
the media because they're this is their
way of trying to show you. They're
trying to show you a certain rel
relativity. You know, it's all the same.
Oh, so so let's ignore the hundred
anecdotes of Muslims killing Christians
and let's find the one anecdote of a
Christian attacking Muslims, let's say
in New Zealand, for example, you know,
the church attack and let's hype that
up. And so the image becomes oh actually
Muslims are being persecuted. So it's
it's these are the many things that you
know the media and the political and the
politicians and the talking heads engage
in that I find kind of frustrating and
it's it's it's by will it's in it's
willful design. This isn't we can't say
anymore that this is they're naive. No,
this is an intentional um you know
camouflage that they're offering.
you have one massive advantage uh to
everybody who engages in this topic and
this is you speak Arabic. So you can
actually listen in and read the the you
know the material both the source
material but also let's say the more
modern interpretations of it. So there
was about 15 years ago when ISIS was
just starting there was one headline in
the London Times that caught my eye and
the headline said more British Muslims
joined ISIS than the British armed
forces. So my question to you is if this
is something you want to speak about,
what makes particularly for young men,
but also we had this case in Austria
about two women who joined ISIS and
they're now returning to Austria and
there were similar cases also in the UK
and other places. So if we want to comp
compartmentalize this a little bit, what
do you think makes this ideology
interesting or attractive both to men
but apparently also to to women? What
would be your your gut feeling why that
is the case? No. Yeah, that's a good
that's a good question which I've
actually looked into about 20 years ago
and wrote specifically about this the
attraction of it and um you know there's
many aspects to it but first of all I
think in the west men are so emasculated
by design and beat down and you know
told to become women essentially or
they're bad people and a lot of them do
that and a lot of them you know deep
down inside resent it. So, in a way, you
know, the Islamic jihadist is a sort of
like a like a heroic pirate figure that
I can see a lot of young men gravitate
towards. Oh, look, he's masculine,
obviously. Um, he's a warrior and he's
pious. He's doing this for God. He
doesn't stand for any nonsense. You
know, he'll decapitate you if you do the
wrong thing. So,
a little bit. What's that? So, the
Andrew Tates type a little bit. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. That like
that. Um, I think that's very appealing
to a lot. And it's also I wouldn't it
wouldn't be appealing if you know a more
robust form of Christianity was allowed
to vent um as it did historically and as
as the as the characters I write about
for example defenders of the west the
book I mentioned you know these were
Christians they didn't find anything
about Islam appealing but they also
understood that their own
religion allowed for them to express
their masculinity and um you know a
patriarchical society and to fight back
you know tit fortat and that sort of
thing. So absent that as we have now
where you know to be a Christian is just
you know to become a doormat. I mean
that's that's essentially I think the
most popular form of Christianity we
have right now in the west you know as I
call it dormat Christianity. Obviously,
a lot of people just don't men don't
find that appealing and women as well.
You know, you were pointing out the
women. I think even women um because
Islam is still traditional and
patriarchal, a lot of women are finding
that more appealing than the mainstream
message of how a woman should be in woke
Western culture. Um which is a turnoff
obviously for many women as well, you
know, and you know, and good for them.
um obviously that they the only outlet
again the only outlet available to them
is something like Islam because even
though Europe had its own traditional
understanding of femininity um that has
been so suppressed that but they do see
the Islamic side um that's allowed to
vent and it's being promoted openly in
Europe so I think it becomes appealing
to them in that sense so you discarded
the uh the grievance argument and I
think you make a very good case why this
is is not a particular useful argument
but if I play devil's advocate for a
second and I spin the grievance argument
a little bit and say, well, would it be
fair to say that modern political Islam
is a reaction to modernity or is a
reaction to what you just described that
it's it's it's less a it's less on the
just religious but actually also
reactionary in a sense that as you said
right the emasculation if you want of of
manhood in the west then led to the
resurgence of Islam because it doesn't
appear weak or feminized that it seems
that it still has these quote unquote
patriarchal masculine values that it's
not so much a an autonomous religion/
ideology that emerged but that it
actually is a reaction to something that
that quote unquote went wrong in the
west. Yeah, I actually don't agree with
that because it's not really a matter of
either or. You know, it can be both. Um
and I do believe that I in fact I've
written a lot about how it's a reaction
to the west what we're seeing and uh you
know if you look back at the history of
Islam and you know the colonial era you
know I always argue that Islam is might
makes right and that's the logic and
that's why Muslims gravitated towards it
for centuries. It actually elevated you
because now you can fight back and you
can plunder and you can enslave people
and doing so makes you righteous. Okay.
And then with the colonial era,
everything was shifted. Now the west
became historically the west was the
underdog. It was the one that was being
beaten and chipped away at. And people
don't know that, but it finally made its
ma major comeback with the colonial era.
This is where the west is ascendants
now. And um it's in the Islamic world
and all in Asia and Africa etc. And
believe it or not, in that time in the
1800s and very early 1900s, Muslims were
very western looking, which means they
looked up to western people because they
were more powerful than them and they
wanted to emulate them. You know, if you
look at Turkey, uh the Ottoman Turkish
Empire, which was the scourge of
Christendom for centuries, and it was a
standard bearer of jihad, it was also
the first country to immediately get rid
of all of its Islamic wrappings and
become as western as it possibly could.
Um under Adaturk, the great modernizer,
it got rid of the Arabic script and and
adopted the Roman alphabet. Um you know,
it became all the men shaved and wore
suits. So you what you had is um you
know the west was unapologetically
triumphant and the Islamic world was
trying to emulate that and then you get
let's say in the 60s everything swi
switches around and now the west hates
itself add the you know rejects itself
loves every other culture promotes every
other culture the emasculation
emasculation we're talking about the
sexual perversion and depravity all that
you know 60s stuff comes in and it
really turns off lots of Muslims all
around the world you at this in the
writings of Sey Kut um you know the the
chief theor theoretician of the Muslim
Brotherhood who visited America I
believe in the 50s um and was appalled
at what he saw and and the idea became
you know take from the west their
scientific knowledge and technology and
and you know their way of doing things
but definitely let's stay with our own
culture because they've lost their minds
essentially and obviously they're
thinking that even more so now when they
see this transgender nonsense going on
um so definitely there's a a certain
level Muslim reactionary um going on to
what they're what they're seeing as
happening in the west but at the same
time it is still intrinsic to the
religion and that's what makes it so
potent. It's not just a reaction that
you know came out of a vacuum that is
the religion the religion is hyper
masculine hyper patriarchal hyper
intolerant but you know by nature so you
know the two of them are feeding into
each other. Do you think there's always
a debate about we hear this now for
example in Syria right with the new the
new leadership in Syria is there
something how would you define the idea
of of a moderate political Islam or is
there no such a thing is this just
something that westerners like to tell
themselves so that they can sleep better
at night yeah it's the latter um in
Muslim and I say this based on what
Muslims say and and Muslims have
repeatedly Erdiggon himself has said
there is no he mo he mocked the term
moderate Islam as an insult because and
it really is it's an adjective. It's
qualifying Islam. Islam is submission.
That's what the word means. Submission
to the laws and the words of Allah and
his prophet as captured in the Sunnah
and the hadith, the Quran, etc. Okay, so
where's the moderation? It's black and
white. It's either you do this or you
don't do that. Okay, moderation suggests
that somehow, you know, Muslims are
going to take the body of Islam and
they're going to moderate it to adapt to
Western uh sensibilities, let's say, or
modern sensibilities. And they can do
that. I don't argue that that I'm not
saying that can't be done. So I do
believe there are moderate Muslims
because Muslims are individuals who are
subjective, but I don't believe there's
a moderate Islam. Islam is what Islam is
and it's it's what it has been
historically and it's a very black and
white religion. There's no shades of
gray. In fact, according to Islamic law,
there's five categories uh that every
act in life fall within which is
forbidden, disliked, not recommended to
do, neutral, uh recommended, you you can
do, we should do, but you don't have to,
and obligatory. Everything in life falls
into that. So, you know, how does the
concept of, you know, western moderation
fit into that? It doesn't.
You are an expert both on on the history
of Islam and also on the history of
Christianity. So one thing I was always
wondering is if we would compare the
split in in Christianity particularly
between Catholicism and Protestantism
and the split in in Islam between Sunni
and Shia. Could you illuminate a little
bit for us how big are the differences
between Sunni Muslims and Shia Muslims?
Is it comparable to the to the to the
split within the Catholic Church or is
it completely different?
It's it's it's you know it's both. It's
comparable but it's also very different.
um you know the Catholic Protestant
split as we know comes around with
Martin Luther on 1517 you know and
basically now you have the printing
press and people have access to the
Bible and they're just saying okay what
the clergy is telling us a lot of it
doesn't make sense it doesn't comport
with scripture so now we want to split
okay the Sunni Shia split was actually
based on succession you know and people
forget this it was basically um you have
the first four righteous khalifs after
Muhammad khalif means successor to
Muhammad And um finally it really came
down to it was we want now we want the
descendants of Muhammad via his cousin
Ali and Muhammad's daughter Fatima.
Okay. So therefore the Shia wanted um
the Khalif to become to be somehow a
blood descendant of Muhammad whereas the
Sunnis wanted just whoever is capable
the best you know uh fit man for the
job. Uh so that's the origin of it
really uh right around 650 or 660. Um
but since then since that breakup um
obviously the Shia and the Sunnis have
also theologically had um vast
differences. The the Shia are very
mystical and they have very esoteric
almost occult-like um teachings whereas
the Sunnis are a little more pragmatic
and mainstream but ironically the Sunnis
are I would argue more intolerant and
more violent towards the non-Muslim. Uh
in fact the Shia they perfected the
concept of tea which is you know living
in deceit you know living am lying
pretending to be you're not what you are
pretending to like who you hate etc and
they did that because they lived amongst
Sunnis and the Sunnis had they known
their Shia they would have persecuted
and killed them um so that's why the
Shia really perfected the art of tea
even though all Muslims including uh
Sunnis engage in it but anyway so and
also it's important to keep in mind that
you know I don't know the exact numbers
but I think maybe All the world's
Catholics versus the world's Protestants
number-wise are probably similar. I
don't know, maybe Catholics are more.
Whereas the Sunni Shia thing, it's about
90% Sunni, you know, and Shia are
essentially mostly in Iran, but other
smaller countries nearby also as well.
So, they're, you know, more or less
politically disenfranchised except for
Iran, which is obviously a powerful
nation. Um but yeah that that they um
you know historically they would fight
each other when no one else is there but
once the infidel comes in then they side
together it's which makes sense you know
we're still close enough to be allied
against the total outsider but once we
don't have problems with the outsider
then we fight amongst each other one one
of the reasons I was asking this
question is because since 2001 there
must have been or it failed what felt
like a million articles saying what
Islam needs is a reformation. what Islam
needs is their own Martin Luther and
some would say that Martin Luther in
fact was a radical himself. So that
might be the worst thing to happen. So
and I'm sure you came across these
articles as well. What is your reaction
to this idea? Is it even possible? Is is
let's say radical Islam the reformation
of Islam that we saw actually happening
or is there something coming in the
future that would resemble something
like I think when people say reformation
what they actually mean is is a
secularization of religion. Do you think
that's currently in the cards in the
near future, you know, in the long run
everything is possible or do you think
once again this is something where where
the optimism gets the better part of us?
Yeah, I do think that what people mean
by reformation or when they think of
Martin Luther and the Protestant
Reformation, something akin to that has
actually already happened and it has led
to what we call radical Islam or better
known as Wahhabiism or Copifism and I'll
explain but basically you know both
Christianity and Islam when you go back
down the centuries again before the
printing press the people who knew what
Islam was all about were the they're
known in Arabic as the which means the
scholars of Islam. They were the ones
who were literate. Your average Muslim,
just like your average Christian in
Europe, was not literate. And even if
they were, there were no copies of the
Bible or the Quran, respectively. So
most people just believed what they were
told by the leaders. Um and but now with
now with the printing press and
everything's available now today you
have the internet and anyone can just at
a you know just you know click of a
button they have the entire Quran on
their screen the hadith which was very
hard to access and in fact westerers
this the orientalists were the ones who
really collated it for Muslims um now
it's all available and Muslims like
westerners are a lot more literate and
what happens is so now and now and you
even have a figure who is Martin Luther
and his name is Muhammad bin Abdul wahed
Saudi and he was allied with the Saudis
and what he he's known as a reformer.
They refer to him as a reformer. What he
did is he said look when we read the
Quran and the hadith etc it's black and
white but a lot of there there had been
a lot of accretions that built into
Islam over the centuries that were not
necessarily part of the original corpus.
So they cleaned it all out and the net
result um from a nah Muslim perspective
is very much more radical. Uh there was
it was actually tempered in a way uh
because it just evolved organically and
people had to be able to live with each
other and their neighbors to some
extent. But uh a a strict black and
white reading of the scriptures is such
that it makes it even more radical. And
um and and it really comes down to a
simple question which is you know how
can Christians how can Muslims and
Christians do the same thing which is
lead the the clergy and the authorities
and focus on their scriptures and yet it
leads to something diametrically opposed
and the simple answer of course is the
Bible and the Quran are so different and
you know and to to your ob to your
typical secularist they won't get that
because they just lump all religious
books together. Uh but you know the New
Testament teaches monogamy, Islam
teaches polygamy and sex slaves,
concubinage. Uh you know, the New
Testament teaches forgiveness. Uh Islam
is about vengeance. Uh in the New
Testament, you're supposed to pray for
your enemies. And if someone leaves
Christianity, an apostate, they're not
supposed to be um executed in Islam.
They are. So this is why, you know, a
return to the scriptures, which has
happened for both religions, is really
uh bringing out what they're all about.
But the other point is yes and this is
the problem. Most people when they talk
about a reformation what they mean is
they want Islam to undergo an
enlightenment which is really different.
An enlightenment would be Muslims
basically saying okay you know that
that's enough of that. Uh we need to
like rise above these teachings of
Islam. They're obviously you know
they're not for our times and you know
they can rationalize it whichever way
they want. Um, and you know that happens
as well, but there isn't a huge or
mainstream uh example of it because
honestly the be the the cleaner and more
genuine thing a Muslim can do who who
reaches that point is just leave Islam
and that's what happens. They
apostasize, they become Christians, they
become atheists uh or whatever the case
may be. But that's realistically um you
know more in the cards. But to try to to
try to you know adapt Islam so it fits
in neatly with you know modernity is
essentially to just rewrite the entire
religion at which point you know it's it
becomes so insincere for those who are
doing it that you're better off just
starting a new
you you mentioned the printing press and
one very popular comparison with what
what was once the printing press is now
the internet and the reason I'm
mentioning this is um after there were a
couple of prevented terrorist attacks
attacks were attempted terrorist attacks
particularly by young men in Europe. Now
there's this new theory that is
popularized once again in the media
which is that this is a tick tock
radicalization. So it's you know it's
it's young men they they call it in in
in Germany it sounds a bit better but
what they more or less call a high-speed
radicalization. So they say it's it's
young men they watch a couple of Tik Tok
videos and within four weeks they become
radicalized. Um what is what is your
take on this? Because it sounds like
radicalization is like catching a cold.
So, you know, you walk out the day, you
know, you turn on your computer, you
pick up your phone, and then you watch
the wrong video, and three weeks later,
you start to to plan a terrorist attack.
Is this I don't know, kind of always
come back to the same question, but I'm
so curious about your take on this, but
do you think this is once again us not
taking the actual depth of the ideology
and the message seriously enough if we
argue that, well, this is just a couple
of, you know, mentally ill or unstable
young men who watch a handful of Tik Tok
videos and then decide they want to
become jihadist. Yeah. Right. that I I
associate it with what we spoke about
before, which is it's another one of
those sorts of excuses to side s side s
side s side s side s side s side s side
s side s side s side sidestep the real
issue at hand which is the teachings
themselves and just say oh this is a
frustrated youth who was having a bad
patch in his life and he watched this
video and it just threw him over the
edge you know and that's exactly what
they say. um you know could there be
truth to that you know with this and
that individual sure there's all sorts
of precursors to why people do what they
do but again you know it's always
they're always they continue to sidestep
the real issue which is the religion
itself promotes this and so when a
person whether they're sane or insane
reads the texts and they say hate hate
the infidel fight the infidel in kill
him slaughter him wherever you can find
him as in Quran 95 the sword verse it is
what it says and uh I can be perfectly
sane and act on it. I'm not insane
because I'm acting on it. So again,
they're they're pointing fingers at the
wrong directions should be pointed at
Islamic teachings and scriptures. Um but
it's intentionally so that they're doing
this.
When when we look at the at the Islamic
world proper, particularly the Arab
world, there is a a lot of hope at least
uh the countries like Saudi Arabia with
Muhammad bin Salman that they try or the
United Arab Emirates that they try to
modernize, they try to push their their
countries into the the future, if you
will, it's a more progressive direction.
That might be a correct way to put it.
And when we talk not so much about the
elites, but if we focus a little bit
more on the people in the the Arab world
particularly, but maybe in the broader
Muslim world, can any form of government
have legitimacy if they don't take
religion at least a little bit into
account? The reason why I'm asking this
is because it seems to me that
especially after the Arab Spring and
after also now the civil war in Syria,
but also in Afghanistan what we saw with
with the return of of the Taliban that
any form of maybe not good governments
but at least stable governments seems to
have some connection to to religious
sources or to the to the matter of
Islam. So is it truly hypothetically
would a truly secular government or
governance ever be possible in that part
of the world? in the short in the short
term. Yeah. On the long term, many
things are possible. Yeah. In the short
term, I doubt it. Um because like you
said, every single one of these um
especially Arab nations, but Muslim
nations in general have some sort of um
uh uh some some stipulations that
involve religion, Islam. As one example,
Egypt um its constitution article two
and I think this was introduced uh under
Sadat Anoir Sadat maybe in the 70s um
basically says legislation in Egypt is
traced back to and based on Sharia okay
and that's very problematic for
non-Muslims the cops of of Egypt they
they often point to that because you
know Sharia is inherently anti- infidel
anti- non-Muslim it's discriminatory so
for example Sharia says you can't build
new churches and you can't even you know
renovate old ones. Guess what? That's
the case in Egypt. It's very very hard
uh for them to even renovate that
Muslims will attack a church that
already exists because they tried to
repair the bathroom uh you know or tried
to build you know two feet high kind of
thing and they they'll just slip out
because it goes back to Sharia and here
you have a nation who actually enshrines
that kind of thinking again to most to
your average westerner when they hear
what I just said you know article 2 is
based on Sharia what's so bad about that
after all we're already told that Sharia
is not bad it's not draconian it's
actually humanitarian etc etc. So you
know the lies are just so multi-layered
um and they help and it's what fuels all
the confusion but yeah most if not all
Arab nations have some sorts of
stipulation or connection back to
Islamic teaching and that is in fact how
they derive their legitimacy.
in your travels and your research is
there any particular country at the
moment that you find uh warrants our
special interest that you have have a
special eye on you know whether it's
maybe Turkey or Saudi Arabia or or
Tunisia or Indonesia is there where you
say okay this is a country the things
that we see happening there that could
be a harbinger for the future this is
what what's happening there will
resonate in in the broader Muslim world
you know I think I think what is always
overlooked and underestimated ignored
it's subsaharan Africa and um you know
ISIS and all these radicals have really
fled to and inundated that continent and
you can see it in the behavior of what's
happening to the Christians there. It's
literally a genocide. I already
mentioned the uh 70 decapitated corpses
found in a church but like I said that's
just you know par for the course that
sort of thing. Maybe it's not 70 but
it's 20 you know every other week or
something like that. It's very very
common. Um and uh they're also it's not
just the slaughter of Christians and
destruction of churches, but it's the
overall radicalization of the Muslims in
those regions and you know it's becoming
a safe haven for all these terrorists.
So I'm not saying it's the most
important at all, but I am saying it's
very much overlooked and ignored and
just you know sidestepped altogether.
And I think it it deserves a lot more
attention than it normally gets,
especially from a humanitarian point of
view. We like to pretend we're
humanitarian. we care, you know, Western
civilization and we're always in if we
go to war, it's for humanitarian
purposes. Well, if that's really the
case, then I think we should kind of
turn an eye over there as well. Um, you
know, I I don't know you know this, but
here in America, black lives matter.
That's a saying, right? After George
Floyd was killed, and it's like, I guess
they do, but they don't matter if it's
if it's thousands of Christians being
killed by Muslims, then we don't talk
about it. Um but aside from that
obviously all the the nations that you
mentioned as well Turkey you know
Erdogon has these grand aspirations of
becoming the neotoman sultan essentially
and Saudi Arabia you know the thing with
Saudi Arabia I understand all this
reform that it's engaged in and so forth
but they're really the source of all the
problems if you want to look at it
because their money with they're so
wealthy from oil they are the chief
disseminators of the radical ideology of
Islam any any mosque you go in Europe or
even in America or in the Middle East.
Um, and it's teaching Wahhabi literature
or copist literature, fundamentalist,
it's all traced right back to Saudi
Arabia and its oil wealth, you know. So,
it's kind of playing this two twopronged
game where it tries to show some sort of
moderation and reform, but at the same
time, it's the nation that's chiefly
funding the radicalization of Muslims
all around the world.
Do you think that one difference maybe
in in the when we talk about Turkey or
Iran is that both Turkey and Iran also
have a strong nationalist or or
civilizational tradition if you want
that the Iranians I were of the of the
Persian past the Turks I of the Ottoman
past that that potentially can um
insulate them a little bit from the more
radical teaching as you just mentioned
that emanate from from a country like
Saudi Arabia for example. Yeah, I do
think that and that is the case in Iran.
even more so because they're technically
a different religion. You know, they're
Shi. Um they have nothing to do with the
Wahhabis. Um same thing with Turkey.
They have their very proud and rich
jihadist um heritage and history um and
their language. That's the thing that
the nations that got conquered or became
Islamic but kept their language such as
Iran, Persia and the Turks. um you know
they do they unlike let's say Egypt you
know I mean they had their own language
the Coptic language which is the faronic
language but it it it was actually it
was actually um under one particular
khif was actually banned and he
threatened to cut the tongues off of the
people they speak it um but yeah
language carries with it culture and so
I think those two nations have their own
sort of destiny if you will but they're
still Muslim u and they still you know
according to them they still uh see
themselves as a standard bearers. Like I
said, Turkey is the final manifestation
for centuries of the standard bearer of
Islam, especially of jihad. Um, and they
still know that and still see that they
regularly that when they have celebrate,
they celebrate, you know, the conquest
of Constantinople, May 29, 1453, and
it's presented as this wonderful day.
And I just laugh because living here in
America, you know, where Americans are
supposed to be ashamed of their heroes
and the statues and monuments are being
destroyed for George Washington and
whoever Abraham Lincoln even um in
places like Turkey, they extol and love
and worship men who were basically ISIS
on steroids and all they did is just
attack innocent regions because they're
Christian, slaughter everyone, rape
everyone, destroy every church. Okay?
and um you know and that's what their
sources say but these are the people
they put on pedestals and pray so it
tells you a lot about you know their
thinking process
if hypothetically your phone would ring
and you know Donald Trump would be on
the other end and he would say Raymond I
want to completely redo the policies the
politics of the United States visav the
the Islamic world the Muslim world uh
and he wants your advice what would be
the core of the advice that you would
give to the current president of the
United States. Well, really the most
fundamental advice I would say which
would be this would apply to the people
but but especially to the to the powers
that be the authorities and the
government is enough with the
whitewashing, enough with the lies.
Okay, let's first start off by as a
blank slate understanding what Islam is,
what Islam is about, its history, its
doctrine. If you do that and and this is
the problem, this is why it's
frustrating. We if you do that,
everything falls into play. then you
know how to treat and how to deal with
Islam becomes a very a product of common
sense. But until you get that first
premise you know situated and as long as
you're still thinking that Islam is
inherently peaceful, Muslims are just
reflecting grievances etc etc you're
going to get nowhere. So you know the
first step is just having an accurate um
understanding of Islamic history and
doctrine.
Raymond, before I let you go, I think
after this conversation, which is very
crucial, where can people find your work
and where do you want them to find your
work? So, what's the best way to find
out the large over of your writings, of
your videos, of your appearances?
Yeah, thanks. The for years, it's been
really my website, raymond
Ibrahim.com, r a y m o n d i b r ah i
m.com, and that's where all my writings
and articles and links links to books,
etc. But I've also been developing my
YouTube channel. So, uh, you can just, I
think if you put my name, it's called
the Holy War channel, but, uh, because I
deal with that theme often from both
sides. Uh, but yeah, it's on YouTube and
I I'm been increasingly doing more
videos and I hope to do some more down
the line, but either one of those should
work. All right, Raymond Diver, thank
you so much for the time and I'm very
much looking forward to having you on
the show again. Great. Thanks very much,
Ralph.
[Music]